Hey,
the Romans used the first person Pronoun Ego,
which survives in the modern romance languages with the colorful range of
pronunciation.
Sure.
Dale,
to address you languages continue using the second person Pronoun,
which is less varied to to do.
Where do
things get more interesting?
When I referred to someone besides you and me,
nominative forms of that word you learned as a definite article drop in for
another visit.
It left for he,
he left where she
actually 11 refers to masculine nouns in general,
not only humans and Isla too feminine nouns.
So for example,
La Casa.
The house is also in the pronoun similar to it or this point too generic nuder
items like oak,
significant Sassy sheet.
I can just seniors,
but usually languages express this as a significant on its own.
Return to the second person and inject a bit of culture,
a bit of politeness to be precise.
Modern Romance languages make a politeness distinction,
at least a binary one between familiar and polite,
who is a familiar or informal pronoun.
Polite pronouns vary in Spain,
Portugal and Italy.
Languages innovated.
Third Person Pronouns to speak to you politely,
including Italian Lay,
Spanish and Portuguese.
We'll see how other languages including Romanian Romansh in French use.
Second person,
plural pronouns to refer to you politely.
Where are we?
Have we vulgar Latin speakers had nose,
notch,
loose noise,
no salad throws.
Literally we others also shows up in western languages including Spanish and
Occitan throws.
Who's altars?
Muso
romance languages have a separate Pronoun for the second person,
plural.
All of you.
Volvo's
Voi as with most haltress Oh south trust you others makes an appearance in some
languages.
[inaudible] Boosie elders,
languages that innovate polite third person pronouns in the singular have the
same polite plurals Laura will stay this stage.
Portuguese and Latin American speakers use otherwise formal pronouns.
It was stay this and we'll stitch to refer to all of you.
Well,
we'll still throws and wash our archaic in French and a romance voce doubles as
a singular polite pronoun.
Well,
Shanti means all of you sing as expected,
but also you sir or madam scene,
the plurals of [inaudible] are used for the day as with nouns nominated plurals
ending in a vowel or found in eastern romance,
accusative plurals with a final s in the west elite Romanian,
Yay
or Ilos,
Spanish Agios French II,
Feminine [inaudible] referred to a group of women or feminine plural nouns.
Italian just uses the genitive formed Laurel for both genders.
Instead,
something's creeping back to the surface again and it's that quirk we learned
about romance verbs,
pronoun dropping in classical Latin,
vulgar Latin,
and most romance languages verbs normally get used on their own without these
subject pronouns you've just learned kind of throw on its own means I sing,
got into on its own means.
You see,
this is emphatically not true of the French romance or a few of their regional
neighbors were the ones optional.
Eggo Canto gives the required,
there's just shot yelled chant.
This is where subject pronouns and verbs interconnect.
They match or agree in person and number.
The subject Eggo goes with Convault.
No swith can't Thomas and so on.
For a sense of this integration.
Take a look at the verb I've been using over and again,
kind of in the present,
indicative with its subject pronouns.
These are the basic personal subject pronouns will build upon as we dig into
object pronouns.
Until then,
keep your Latin vulgar.